bien en esta ocasión vamos a empezar con
una línea así que déjame poner primero
aquí la ecuación de esta línea voy a
decir que es igual a x + 3 y lo que
quiero hacer ahora es graficar todos los
puntos que satisfagan esta ecuación o
dicho de otra manera todos los pares x
con mayer que cumplan esta ecuación y
bueno que nos sale al graficar esta
ecuación pues una línea recta así que
este va a ser mi carera si es este va a
ser mi eje de las x y voy a poner esta
línea recta aquí lo primero que hay que
fijarnos es en la ordenada al origen o
la intersección con el eje de ayer que
es 3 por lo tanto vamos a caminar 3
hacia arriba para poner aquí que esta
recta intersecta en 3 al eje de las 10
123 aquí tengo la intersección con el
eje de las íes elia igual a 3 es decir
que cuando x vale 0 lleva de 3 y después
tengo una pendiente de 1 es decir que
por cada uno que avanzó debo de subir 1
por lo tanto en mi recta se ve más o
menos así y esta es la gráfica de esta
recta ojo quiero volver a repetirlo esta
línea recta representa esta ecuación
debido a que todos los
de esta línea recta son pares ordenados
de la forma x
que satisfacen esta ecuación por ejemplo
si pensamos en x igual a 5 que es lo que
está pasando en x igual a 5 voy a tener
aquí a x igual a 5 y si yo lo meto en
esta ecuación me voy a dar cuenta que la
solución es 85 más 38 por lo tanto el
punto 58 existe en esta línea recta está
situado en esta línea recta es decir que
cada uno de los puntos de esta línea
recta es una solución a esta ecuación o
dicho de otra manera esta línea de recta
es el conjunto de todas las soluciones
que satisfacen esta ecuación pero qué
pasa ahora si me tomo otra ecuación que
es igual a menos x más 3 y la quiero
graficar en este mismo plano cartesiano
pues lo primero que hay que fijarnos es
en su ordenada al origen o en la
intersección con el eje layers la cual
también es 3 y la pendiente es menos 1
por lo tanto es exactamente igual a la
recta que estoy dibujando justo ahorita
porque cuando yo avanzo uno realmente lo
que tengo que hacer es bajar uno y si yo
avanzo una cierta cantidad para seguir
en esa línea recta tengo que bajar la
misma cantidad ésta es la representación
de esta ecuación y es igual a menos x 3
es decir que el conjunto de todos los
puntos que estén en esta recta de morado
son una representación gráfica de esta
ecuación que tengo aquí arriba esta
ecuación de morado ahora bien lo que
realmente quiero preguntarme en este
vídeo es si existe una solución en común
dicho de otra manera lo que voy a buscar
es una solución que cumpla estas dos
ecuaciones simultáneamente y bueno para
eso lo que quiero que te des cuenta es
que esta ecuación de amarillo sea
representada por esta recta de amarillo
mientras que esta ecuación de morado
está representada por esta recta de
morado y cuando hablo de una solución
que cumpla estas dos ecuaciones
simultáneamente otra forma de decir lo
mismo que me estoy preguntando es si
existe un punto que esté en la
intersección de estas dos gráficas que
tengo aquí abajo o dicho de otra manera
un punto que esté en ambas gráficas y
bueno en este caso está muy sencillo ya
lo tenemos es el punto 0 3 este punto es
la solución que cumple ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente fíjate bien si yo pongo
cero en lugar de x en estas ecuaciones
me quedaría 0 + 3 esto es igual a 3
y en la traducción me quedaría y es
igual a menos 03 lo cual también es 3
este punto cumple ambas ecuaciones y
realmente lo que hicimos de una manera
gráfica fue resolver un sistema de
ecuaciones esto es muy importante porque
me tomé dos ecuaciones simultáneamente
la ecuación y es igual a x + 3 déjenme
ponerle aquí que es igual a x + 3 y
también me tomé la ecuación y es igual a
menos x + 3
esta primera ecuación representa una
línea recta en el plano cartesiano esta
segunda ecuación representa otra línea
recta en el plano cartesiano y cuando yo
me pregunto acerca de un punto o una
solución que satisfaga a ambas
ecuaciones simultáneamente realmente lo
que me estoy preguntando es en el punto
de intersección de estas dos gráficas de
estas dos rectas cuando resuelva un
sistema de ecuaciones de una manera
gráfica en lo que me estoy fijando es en
el punto de intersección y bueno en los
vídeos siguientes vas a darte cuenta que
hay varias formas de resolver un sistema
de ecuaciones sin embargo en este vídeo
quiero analizar con mucho cuidado la
forma gráfica de resolver un sistema de
ecuaciones
para esto mejor vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo recuerda lo que estamos buscando
se el punto de intersección entre ambas
rectas así que déjame tomarme la
siguiente recta y es igual a 3 x menos 6
y bueno como quiero crear un sistema de
ecuaciones no voy a tomar otra recta la
recta es igual a menos x más 6 así que
bueno como quiero resolver este sistema
de ecuaciones por el método gráfico lo
que vamos a hacer es la gráfica de ambas
rectas por lo tanto déjenme tomarme aquí
mi eje de leyes déjame tomarme por acá
mi eje de las x estoy haciendo mi plano
cartesiano y dice 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10
y para acá 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 y 123 de hecho puede
haber tomado cualquier papel de gráfica
copiarlo y pegarlo pero bueno ya lo
estamos construyendo a mano así que
vamos a fijarnos en la primera ecuación
la primera actuación tiene como ordenada
el origen a menos 6 la intersección con
el eje de las 10
6 y tiene una pendiente de 3 esto quiere
decir que cada vez que caminamos uno a
la derecha hay que subir tres uno a la
derecha subimos tres
estamos justo 123 si estamos justo aquí
cada vez que caminamos uno a la derecha
subimos tres cuando avanzamos uno
levantamos tres ya tenemos esta ecuación
graficada en este plano cartesiano con
esta línea recta que tengo aquí y es
igual a 3 x 6 se ve de la siguiente
manera más o menos así perfecto ya que
tengo la primera ahora vamos a checar
qué pasa con la segunda y es igual a
menos x más 6 por lo tanto me ordenada
el origen o mi intersección cuando elegí
las 16 y después tengo una pendiente de
menos 1 cuando yo avanzo 1 la derecha
abajo 1 cuando yo avanzo 1 a la derecha
vuelve a bajar 1 cuando yo avanzo 1 a la
derecha vuelve a bajar 1 avanzó y bajo
avanzó y bajo y de hecho date cuenta que
interceptamos al eje de las x justo aquí
en el valor de 66 más 6 me da 0 entonces
en el valor de 6 vamos a interceptar
de las xy perfecto ya tengo mis dos
rectas graficadas ahora lo que quiero es
fijarme en cuál es la intersección de
estas dos rectas para encontrar aquel
punto que satisfaga a ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente la solución que
satisfaga a ambas ecuaciones
simultáneamente y bueno si te das
cuentas más o menos este punto de aquí
que tal vez no se vea tan exacto
precisamente porque lo hice a mano pero
más o menos es este punto de aquí que si
te das cuenta es el 3 en x 1 2 3 en x y
1 2 3 en derechos estos dos puntos estos
dos puntos son el mismo punto y esa
intersección de ambas rectas el punto 33
y bueno espero no haberme equivocado
porque todo esto lo estoy haciendo a
mano sin embargo vamos a identificar lo
y cómo lo rectificamos pues vamos a
poner a equis con el valor de 3 en estas
ecuaciones y vamos a ver si obtenemos el
valor de 3 en que en estas ecuaciones es
decir 3 en 10 tiene que ser igual a 3
veces x pero x vale 3 menos 6 y esta
chica 3 por 39 menos 6 estrés en la
siguiente que me quedaría bueno
llévale tres y xv al de tres también
tres es igual a menos 36 lo cual también
es correcto menos 36 es tres positivos
por lo tanto aquí está mi solución de
este sistema de ecuaciones de una forma
gráfica mi punto de intersección de
ambas rectas es el punto 33 y cuando
digo sistema de ecuaciones al que me
estoy refiriendo esas varias ecuaciones
las cuales tienen varias incógnitas y
bueno digo varias porque estoy pensando
en más de una cada una de las ecuaciones
es una construcción de sus variables y
para encontrar la solución lo que hay
que hacer es encontrar la intersección
de las ecuaciones en los siguientes
vídeos lo que vamos a ver es otras
formas de resolver estos sistemas de
ecuaciones que no tengan que ver con el
método gráfico vamos a verlo de una
manera mucho más algebraica